man welcome to the weekly pool everybody
on Betty the comic story and that is
cell from Tammy pop that is Joel from
Kate Joel and comic book cast too that
is Rob the vape King from comics and
that is Legolas aka Faust from it's
super effective I like like this it's
cool Rob you gotta begin pretty cool all
right today's show we're gonna be
discussing rather briefly what are what
we decide would be our top 5 timeless
comics combined with our reason behind
it some of us can have less than the
options but it's just it's more to give
you an idea of what we consider to be a
timeless comic and we're also going to
be playing Marvel Cinematic Universe
trivia pursue now since they did not
fully decide if it was gonna be teams or
not chat you decide if it's gonna be
teams of two or no we decided it was
gonna be teams we just decide who gets
Faust I only watched the movies once and
then I forget everything that's in them
I'm gonna be screwed
we swear it wasn't a kickball situation
where no one wanted to pick those laughs
who wants Faust and you will win we all
trailed off I think my kitchens on fire
I better go deal with that
all right so Faust is the handicap let's
play at this game
all right here's how we're gonna do this
okay so there's other teams are gonna be
decided we go I'm gonna roll this dice
there's six options Sal pick Iron Man
Captain America Hulk Thor Avengers or
villains I'm gonna go with villains okay
Joel pick one of those of the ones that
he said yeah the ones you just hold I
guess oh okay and Rob what were the
options again you have I pat that
America thorn Avengers left The Avengers
okay I'm gonna roll this to one of your
options come up whoever gets it is fast
teammate
like tired man nobody picked him
Iron Man nobody picked him guys are
freaking loaded Marvel Universe it's
just iron man over and over we got
villains salad faster team I robbed you
meat let's take all their money first
we're gonna talk about our timeless
comics and I'll go first is I'm the one
that threw that under the boat now last
week if you watched the weekly poll raba
Sal and I got into a pseudo Hot Topic
because that because we were discussing
Dark Knight and I said that I'm not a
huge fan of dark knight while I do like
the idea the story I don't like what
people hold like what pedestal is held
up on to that's that was the core of
what I said and I think we think we got
to a really funny thing I called Frank
Miller at Frank Freddy Krueger people
drew pictures it was funny for his art
man he is he is the dude man when it
comes to that just like the crazy stuff
we say he will bring to life to pay for
an anger good on you sir so based upon
so what we discovered though from that
discussion of me not liking how hot how
much of a pedestal people put darknet on
and for the record I don't think I got
to clarify this but I dislike a lot of
stories for that same reason one story
in particular that I do love and a lot
of people love is injustice and I hate
the pedestal and justice has been put on
as this incredible story it's a good
story but it's not incredible well be
for being a digital comic it's probably
the height that digital comics have been
a that's what I'm saying but what I'm
saying is for the same reason I discount
Dark Knight I just got quite a few other
things that people enjoy a lot of
because of the pedestal they're held on
one that Rob and I get into a huge
debate about quite often is Civil War
Rob like and you guys have heard that
debate a lot of times I like Civil War I
don't think it's a it says like almighty
as like Rob would like to make you think
is amazing there's a lot to like about
Civil War but there's also a lot to
unpack when you read when you're like oh
oh and I also think time has been weird
to Civil War too because how many times
have you heard a-holes online hold up
cap speech from that to defend a point
of view oh yeah
Captain America speech is like a
universal standard like everything good
in this world can be justified with
Captain America's speech yeah so anyway
that's what I wanted to clarify from
last week because a lot of people came
to me on Twitter and for something to do
the picture about me saying about Frank
mailer by the way I like Frank Miller
with Sin City I'm not saying he's not I
just don't like the pedestal that he's
getting whatever we're not gonna go into
that argument we did actually put 300
that was pretty amazing to me he's done
some good stuff I just don't like it
when someone's like revered for
something that I don't think should be
on the pedestal I mean it's on good
things when I get is something and this
is I don't think I ever actually got to
say this last week but when I really sat
down and thought about it I really
thought thought like what do I could
like if I were to sit down if someone
goes what are your timeless books what
books would you recommend to somebody
because there's a lot of definitions
behind that be it a book that you could
read whenever and it's still valuable be
it a book that is a game-changer being a
book that that was you know that kind of
a thing for me
it really is game-changing arcs that
change the way comic books are received
mmm and that's what I kind of consider a
timeless book something that I would
recommend you read but it wouldn't be on
the top of my list it would be like I'll
give you my list of things you should
start with and then by the way if you
see these where are these so for me that
list is identity crisis from the from
the DC mmm does it quite a game-changer
they changed the face out villains
handle things it's a lot of how the
universe got darker a lot of people like
to preferring it back to that that it
was always doing that was the point
that's like we're getting darker and
more serious and never adult after was
disassembled because that changed the
face of the Avengers yeah it's one of
those stories that you can read without
too much context and you're like oh [ __ ]
that's always nice that's always nice
snow birds blessed must fly which is the
story into which Green Lantern and green
arrow discovered that speedy is a heroin
addict my favorite meal Adam pieces I
got that sign for him that's up on my
wall people who watch my videos will
know that Geoff Johns Green Lantern run
and that might be a slight biased but it
did change the face of the Lantern Corps
and it's a tired like everyone is still
chasing the Geoff Johns run yeah it's
day no disrespect to any of the new
writers but that still be high wall
marking you know you could throw his
flash in there to that that's still a
very high like his flash but it didn't
change anything like his green lantern
did Green Lantern had created an
entirely new mythos for that character
rewrote the book I mean yeah okay then
in that case you could throw his Aquaman
in there it's yeah there's a little bit
writing yeah and this is the Shocker but
I hold these two in the same tier
Kingdom come in Dark Knight because they
showed the Elseworlds like they show
what could be that kind of a thing they
then explore that possibility like I
said it wasn't I'm not I don't I just
wouldn't recommend Dark Knight as a top
tier go read it right this second you
know and I wasn't against it it just
made for a fun argument did it ever
alright so those are my what I would be
like if you were to sit down and say
okay not your recommended list books
that change the face of comics that you
need that you would read so you have an
idea of what comics are now and the
reason Dark Knight is on there as much
as I I'm not a humongous fan of the
story you were writes out it did change
like people started chasing Frank Miller
after that or better or worse so
following that mentality because I
always thought of Kingdom Come but then
I'll sitting there thinking Kingdom Come
is one of mine cuz that did change like
that gave an idea like superheroes are
fallible they this is where they could
become and a lot of Elseworlds stories
following that change I'm pretty sure
like things like red Sun and stuff like
that came all afterwards if yeah or
right around but that was all the same
concept superheroes are in are wrong in
some aspects yeah yeah yeah I would like
to say injustice is based entirely on
that concept oh yeah oh yeah no question
Oh
injustice is basically DC's in
continuity Watchmen by lesser people
like it and I was thinking like though
the writers are bad I'm just saying like
in a watch what they want Watchmen to be
like it's what it's you know it's
Michael Bay's Watchmen it did wonders
for Tom Taylor's career though and
Marguerite Bennett helped out with that
with that well there's there's some
great stuff in there surprisingly enough
but anyway so those are mine um since
we're on a slight time constraint Casal
rob doesn't have all night to go and
sell normally has to take off after this
salad since you and I were the two big
debaters you're timeless books uh
timeless books okay we got a couple of
repeats Kingdom Come for obvious reasons
I've got preacher on there I think it's
a timeless comic because my criteria is
like it changed the face of comics or it
is a story that is evocative of the
human condition and it can min and you
can set it pretty much at any time and
the fact that you can make preacher
Western or a future story or present day
in either way works you've done all
those variations yeah you making an AMC
show and we'll see where that goes
yeah you can make it bad looks perfect
though I mean we talked we talked we
talked about Watchmen watchman's on my
list because Watchmen is another thing
that like just completely shifted the
entire superhero balance and it changed
the face of graphic novels the face of
comics in general boned by Jeff Smith is
on there because it's another story that
is it changed I don't have to change the
face because you kind of Elfquest before
that but uh you have it's a it changed
the way people looked at like
kid-friendly comics I think bonuses how
many books
comedy book company book the same sort
of respect that all these other shocked
to hear bone because like Beau and I
would never consider to be a timeless
book I mean Lord of the Rings timeless
if you consider like Lion the Witch and
the Wardrobe styles I think bone is
right up in there no I if you're putting
those on the same to you I could totally
see that I just I never would have
thought of bone in that manner you know
yeah it's true there's a couple like a
list of ten but I'm not gonna unhitch
rivalry Pete's off fine I'm sure rob is
gonna talk about God loves me and kills
I'm gonna let him take that one
Marvel's another one where it's cemented
in the time that it came it's literally
a representation if it's robbed that's
on your list I won't talk too much about
it the fact is like we it was it was
arguably like when we first got to see
Alex Ross make or realize our heroes in
the flesh almost like it's close to
thinking we got until the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yeah let's see Mouse
by Art Spiegelman is another book that
changed the face of comics and
completely shifted everything it showed
it made it played with the format but
while also giving us something real and
scary and dark
and and and valuable let's see
Dark Knight Returns on their lone wolf
and cub I got to put on there this isn't
a debate episode guys when I heard a
debate everyone's choices exactly not
like well wrong you're right why we tell
you Dark Knight Returns over dark night
well dark dark well what what dark night
like what you think if Dark Knight
strikes again that ya know I always yeah
that's my returns actually might
actually talk about this a lot in our
Dark Knight 3 conversation but I'll say
now it's just I put Dark Knight Returns
in there because Dark Knight Returns is
it was the first Batman story to shatter
the pop culture mindset of what Batman
was supposed to be from up until 1986
everyone everyone who didn't read comics
cuz you had Neal Adams who already made
Batman into like a real person
the world at large
saw Batman as a groovy cat who danced
his way through and not was a silly
idiot who would like put makeup over his
mustache yeah like legitimately it
wasn't until like Time magazine wrote a
review of it and it became a New York
Times bestseller comic and like people
started to read it I mean Stephen King
espouses about Dark Knight Returns Tim
Burton uses it as references as
reference material his version of the of
the movie that then inspired the pop
culture's mindset of who Batman is
posted man it it caused the domino
effect for the Batman character right no
I'd actually was my mistake up for
summary that I always mentally think
Dark Knight and the Dark Knight Returns
is this yeah because it's like well in
actuality it's dark never turns and then
strikes again and that's where I get a
mixed up I just one of those things I
always confuse in my head like Dark
Knight and the Dark Knight Returns is
this ya know it's it is all what I was
asking was because I thought you put the
sequel on there oh why did you pick the
sequel over the first one like after our
whole debate you went with debate
because experiment with digital colors
and yes that's what I was asking cuz I
got the bed use the title I'm sorry yeah
then I wouldn't have I wouldn't have
spent so much time I was like no I it's
cool that you explained it I'm just
saying like no I get I get
Dark Knight being and you know so if we
could talk more about them but like the
last one I'm gonna put on there and it's
not technically a comic book but it's a
comic strip that changed everything and
informs what most people want like what
most people our age want to see in
comics Calvin and Hobbes
yeah that's a good one it is timeless
you could set it any time you can read
any time you give it to children from
any time and they'll read it and the
creator didn't sell out or didn't at
least you know like sell out his
property the same as no count-outs
caught like calendars window magnets or
you know suction cup dolls or if you'd
kept it up here yeah he kept it pure and
uncut Calvin and how could have done
more but he didn't like you know suicide
now what is he doing now the new owner
said he learns he learned to play the
guitar he tried to experiment what
colors and the last time we saw him was
in a documentary about comic strips
called stripped in which he finally came
out of hot out of hiding and did like an
audio interview and shared his feelings
he also drew and painted the poster for
the movie so it's the first technical
Bill Watterson cartoon that you've seen
since like yeah because I remember that
was like his big thing Bill Watterson
was like I own Kevin Hobbes no one's
gonna do anything with it and I'm never
gonna come out say anything I'm never
gonna do anything I'm just about the
Ditko rad you know just gonna say he's a
Steve Ditko's alive everybody it's just
you no one has any pictures of him from
the last 30 years yeah legit yeah and
Bill Lars the same deal the only
pictures people have of him is his self
caricatures that he'd like submitted for
books and stuff I think it's it's it's
spectacular okay no those are great
options feel like this isn't the debate
episode we did that last no exactly and
we all want to see how much knowledge
Kraus knows I know lots about comics
just it's okay for him to say that
that's uh well you know III I approached
my five a little differently than you
guys cuz again like cell said before I
imagine you guys would have the big ones
like the kingdom comes in the Dark
Knight Returns everything I kind of
split mine up by writer character run
and then story in that run that I really
like obviously of course
anyone who knows me I'm a gigantic green
arrow fan a lot of green arrows stories
I could have paid for I was actually
really surprised really happily
surprised that Benny picked green
lantern green arrow one that was nice
I picked one from the Winnick run it's
my favorite run and it's a heading into
the light from that run which was the
big one where dr. light came back to
fight him and basically after building
his life up and making him really happy
green air when giving him his new family
and his new status quo everything winix
like okay let's tear this all down then
like so jestro comes after him and
constantine Drakon comes after him and
then at the end like Merlin's like it
was me all along green arrow it was me
Merlin who was pulling the strings he's
like ah and then they fight in the park
and they're just stabbing each other and
it's this whole big deal like man how's
this gonna end and then it technically
didn't end cuz then they do like the
like the five years later thinking like
the five months later they jumped
forward to the future but it's a great I
like this story cuz this very easily
could have been the last word ever
written on green arrow it feels very
much like a story but say you could have
ended it right there and you would have
gone out on a high note and I feel
that's a thing in comics where because
some of these characters have been
written for upwards of 75 years we're
never gonna get a final story we're
never gonna get an end so it feels nice
when a writer goes now you can just tag
out here if you want
and that's happen I like that that's why
I like that one uh and another one that
I think is just like you know
landmark run you only really need to
know this and you will understand
everything about the character that is
Garth and is Punisher max oh god my list
but that's a good one to pick that is
what's going on that's everything in the
character that you know you read that
you understand it is mean spirit and
uncut as it needs to be and in the way
that only Garth Ennis could deliver to
everyone if I had to pick a particular
story from that it would be the story
Widowmaker and that's when a bunch of
the wives of a bunch of the mafiosos
that Punisher is killed over the year
start basically like a book club like
they come together and say look you know
the police will never give us justice
because our husbands were mafiosos let's
kill the Punisher ourselves and is of
all these women like yeah it focuses
more on these women trying to kill the
Punisher and it asked these really like
really interesting moral Quan
about revenge and what is right words
like are these women evil for seeking
revenge on the Punisher when he himself
has not avenged his family a hundred
times over and if anything he's going
crazier in his old age cuz the woman
running the group is like you know in
one night the punisher killed my husband
my father and my two sons at a birthday
party he opened up with a machine gun
and killed all of them in one night I'm
like oh does this lady not deserve her
revenge I don't know
Oh all-star Superman which I'm surprised
no one mentioned yet yes again like so
many people go mad for Faust he's gonna
be the end of you like what's left you
guys have said nothing that's on my
lesser side that's because I mean like
so many people say I don't get Superman
man I don't understand him how do you
like a character who's so powerful and
so godlike after it's like read this
book and you will understand read that
what I mean Morrison gets it all done in
just like a couple stories it's just
like yep that's all of Superman just
condensed into one book what's beautiful
is it's not even it's not even it's a
definitive Superman for if you want that
Superman but you can read another
version and it's the definitive Superman
for another version a Mark Waid Superman
which is a totally different Superman
that's also timeless that yeah that book
is amazing both look back on the
powerless Superman as a mom and that'll
be great
or how about red and blue red and blue
oh those are already classics yeah I
mean I have a poster of it like
everything about all-star Superman too
as he gives me one of my favorite
cop-out arguments and that is he's not
dead he's just fixing the Sun and he'll
be back later yeah I mean we did a
backhoe Sun and I'm like and he's dead
and they're like oh no in DC 1 million
he returned and I'm like all right the
second year save DC 1 million yeah but
my last two here uh this was really hard
picking one cuz I think he's a character
who has had some of the greatest
successions of writers ever and that is
daredevil I'm picking the Bendis run cuz
it was the first run that I ever was
oh he goes up and down so much and if I
had to pick a particular story from that
daredevil run and there's like a million
great stories in the venda story I mean
the friggin Murdock papers and all this
other stuff but the one I picked was it
was a little bit more of an obscure one
and that is the Golden Age and the
Golden Age is this old retired mobster
who Matt Murdock put away he was like
the kingpin of Hell's Kitchen before the
kingpin comes back and he's old and his
wife died when he's in prison and he now
knows that Matt Murdock is daredevil
because that was the story when his you
know
secret identity got leaked to the world
world and he enacted this plan he
manipulates the gladiator into fighting
on his side in everything and he shoots
up with a bunch of mutant growth hormone
it's just like him trying to take apart
Matt Murdock's life and that Murdock
can't fight this old man because if he
does people are gonna know that he's
daredevil and then compounding this
story further this was also the story
that Angela del Toro the white tiger was
first introduced
oh cool as an FBI agent who was tracking
daredevil but then eventually gets the
amulet and says look my uncle killed
himself when you were representing him
in court you got to help me be a hero
and Daredevils like cutting himself off
from the world at this point okay fine
I'll come out of retirement and help you
do this and then he does and then the
end of the story is just him letting
this old man hopped up on drugs beat him
up in the middle of the square cuz he's
like okay you know I just gotta take my
beatin here cuz he's old and his heart
will eventually give out and it does and
that's how daredevil wins the fight by
letting this old angry man wail on and
that's a good story I really like that
one Jules really going in-depth into his
stories it was really good comic story
in Episode a man if we got to do one of
these maybe that's a crossover reason my
final one and this is a total personal
pick for me I love Gail Simone and I
love her work on the secret six I love
d-list villains I think this was the
book that really helped elevate them and
say you know duty list villains are
people to man with thoughts and feelings
and pathos and the particular story from
that I picked was cat's cradle and this
was the one that rien visioned the
character of Cat Man as someone you know
actually worthwhile and not a crappy
character and it was
him trying to get his son back he he
basically does taken before taken was a
thing and like cabinets to aerial skills
it's just like that he's beaten up dudes
in Africa and even the end of the story
where we find it's like well why did
they kidnap cat man's kid and it's like
we kidnapped him because we wanted to
give him a better life because he will
only continue this lifestyle of villainy
if you continue to race him and be in
your land I think like chesh Eyre is his
mom - yeah Cheshire Eyre was the kid's
mom and it's like this kid is
predisposed to villainy at this point
like genetically predisposed and we are
going to try and give him a better life
and in the end cap man goes yeah yeah
you're right you should take my kid away
you should give him a better life and he
makes this really difficult choice and
it's like dude why am i caring about cat
man so cat man's kid's name was Joel
Daly DL is in Canada and that's my five
all right Rob let's vape it up
get against get a good head get a good
pop in um well number one on my list
damn Jergens death the Superman Wow
really really you know what it's like I
I would say that's one of the most
iconic images in comics
yeah can I just say that Sal and I need
to spend some like kids for my 90s
commercials it's like ya know I I picked
that because it killed Superman it he'll
have the most iconic superhero of all
time and to me that story will pan that
has stand the test of time as being
timeless people will always look back
and if they remember anything about
comic books don't remember the time that
Superman died yeah three it's a timeless
story because you could you could pick
it up at any point in time and read it
you know and even you know with the
Justice League at the time whatever it
is you can just a Superman died oh my
god Superman's dead especially you know
the ending scene you know where he's
he's laying there dead you got Batman
you got all these superheroes there and
it's you know
um the next one was Days of Future past
I just yeah I did I called as a future
pass because you can read it in
isolation you don't need to know
anything else it's wearing that coat
it's the worst case scenario for mutants
what if they feel like what if what if
humanity turns against means you know
what if the x-men failed completely you
know that to me there's never been a
stories have been written in the history
of Marvel Comics where the x-men have
failed so disastrously that you know
they allow the assassination of
McTaggart Xavier and Senator Kelly to
happen and Days of Future past took
place so to me that that's a timeless
one um the next one is Superman number
76 from 19 whenever it was when when
when Batman and Superman first met that
was when they officially first met in DC
establish the shared continuity no
that's not in part that is a very
important one has a tax rate because it
allowed for them to start crossing
characters over what's what's the Marvel
equivalent of that like Namor Human
Torch from lights a back and other
support number wherever we're like
spider-man first showed up Obie's wanted
no one okay yeah then yeah and that's it
the next one and this was actually an
interesting one
Warren Ellis's rumens hey now this love
right that's dude it was so good it's
what like the worst it's a really dark
story it's really really messed up but I
considered to be a timeless one because
everybody knows the superheroes well the
question what would it be like if it
didn't happen that way
yeah if they were just monstrosities you
know instead and then finally my last
one and I think you know people who
follow me out how much coffee will know
this Paul Jenkins and Jay leaves this
century a century and I picked that as a
timeless one because of how it was
written because they made it look like
the century had been around all that
time is over the case you could read it
by itself you know you don't need to
know the the ins and outs of all the
superheroes you know all you need to
know is you know who Xavier is who that
a handful of people are and the way it's
done I think it's probably one of the
best written stories in the history of
Marvel but I guess said that to be a
timeless story but like the only soul of
the century ever got right
but it sucks yeah yeah it's a lot of
really screwed us hair dryer the only
one worth talking about yes I don't kiss
on a man I'd and then he broke it I was
I was gonna say spider-man one more day
but I don't want to bring up that whole
you know the the last discussion we had
held me to understand that I was I was
apparently wrong about spider-man world
over the chat helped me to understand
that I was wrong at a public opinion
like popular opinion is where I should
go with so spider-man one more day is
obviously a bad story yeah you know
that's the thing about comics do
everything we said you know history
sometimes things come back around for
stories so maybe one day something the
popular opinion will start swinging the
other way you have a lot of people in
your corner there a lot of people who
are like I don't care like I'm just glad
that Mary Jane's gone it's okay
so I think my point of view of a
timeless comic is a little bit different
all of yours but I'm foreign so that's
okay it's my favorite excuse I could get
awake murder because of it I think my my
point of view of what a timeless comic
is is that no matter when you are born
you can relate to it and it's messages
kind of still hold up but and so because
of that looks like the same reason that
people see the Cat in the Hat and the
Lord of the Rings as both timeless
stories so those are the rigs timeless
but the hairstyles will live forever I
love your elvish bread
actually really good Faust I don't give
you a lot of crap for I'm coming back to
silver hair in a few days anyways by the
moral of the story kids is never be
different or else people will harp on
that thing that's different
so basically never be friends with a guy
so number one on my most timeless coming
before you do that I'm interrupting you
on purpose the chat is all saying
incoming Teen Titans spoiler alert it's
fights that there are no Teen Titans on
this list really no so we've got flex
mantle oh man oh muscle mystery by Grant
Morrison Morrison of course because look
the whole point of that story is it was
divided into four issues and each issue
is a phase of your life and it's all
about taking responsibility for your
life and sort of you know finding out
who you are and sort of not being an
[ __ ] bearing semi-autobiographical
for Morrison at that point in his life
yeah and we all need to learn to not be
[ __ ] say that that's timeless it's a
good message that's there yeah that's no
dumb message but no mm-hmm Grant
Morrison's Doom Patrol uh Morrison thing
is this because I think not everyone can
relate to this but I think people that
read comics will be able to relate to it
because if you read comics you're
probably considered a bit of a freak
growing up radio cast heroes yeah and
the people in the Doom Patrol are like
x-men times 1 million not only were they
freaks they were considered a danger to
those around them and because of that
they were weird they were true outcasts
they make the x-men look like the
popular kids so because of that I just
you know did you ever read the Doom
Patrol secret six crossover they did
that was really cool yeah because
they're like look you're the Freak
outcast villains and we're the Freak
outcast heroes we should work together
forget the Legion of Doom forget the
Justice League I will fight anyway then
we got death the high cost of living
mmm again we all need to learn the value
of life we all need to take
responsibility for our own lives and
when you all need to learn to just not
be so negative
all the time which is something I think
YouTube commenters could are you trying
to give a hint to the people watching
the stream hint hint
and I don't know Teen Titans on this
list but I do have Young Justice the
person who put a bet in and lost $5 do
you now win because they're gonna have
to debate that forever like is it is
Young Justice technically a teen titans
book no it's not a teen titans button
let me tell you for why the Teen Titans
the whole point of that book is it's
very grounded in the time it was
released in which then like the opposite
of being timeless in my definition of
timelessness I mean oh yeah it's like
the 80s teen titans looks like it's the
thing out the 80s the Teen Titans from
2003 looks like it's from the early
2000s Young Justice doesn't have a time
you could read that any point it's like
alright that this is a comic that was
written at some point I guess right
that's true it's also kind of like ties
into my number 5 which is Robin because
of the combination of Young Justice and
Robin Teen Titan like teen characters
and younger characters actually started
being written like younger characters
and up to that point younger characters
were kind of written like adults or
miniature adults sometimes had to go
through weird stuff but well there were
petulant brats who were like yeah yeah
even spider-man who always gets like the
you know he was the first young hero you
know with real young people proms he was
still you know adults writing young
people problems
whereas Young Justice it was like these
kids are having fun being heroes and
then suddenly they realize oh [ __ ] we
could die doing this so grace lit up and
like it was a big thing like oh they
were their reactions were actually like
young people and that was the first time
that that was done in comics and I like
that I'd always do that now let me ask
you this I'm gonna be doing a Young
Justice comic really
soon on my channel should I do the
original or that remake comic did they
base the TV show on that rehab odd on a
C's felt and I may need to go to war
over that cuz I'm a big fan of the Young
Justice TV show I know it's nothing like
the comics I appreciate that but I had a
comic based on a Joel that's what I'm
talking I know they did okay look okay
you know I will say look at the comics
not as good as not going it's not as
good as the show now okay how do you
take a conic that's all about emotions
and interactions and figuring out who
you were as a teenager and oh my god
I've got powers and puberty how the [ __ ]
do I do this - lets fight some bad guys
every week guys it's simple
alright guys are timeless books that's
what we consider to be timeless and what
we chose to be them um jump start critic
did a great idea babe site that's what
we can see your tiny them yeah ah that's
what we considered to be them I don't
inless speak me no we got a good ear up
all around alright guys so basically you
all want a Jessica Jones spoiler caster
will probably be bringing you a separate
episode for that allowed me to watch it
at your leisure as opposed to trying to
spoil the for you early on I haven't
even started it yet so I have a week now
to do that but I thought of a great idea
I'm totally taking credit for this I
thought of a great idea as a replacement
for today's show and that is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe trivia Pursuit that I
saw at games not pretend Oh was that a
Black Friday buyer was that like an
impulse buy as you were on an emerald
why today while I was in the store
getting Just Cause and I was like oh god
what are we gonna talk about they wanted
that Jessica Jones thing I don't want to
be a part of that what could we do
thanks game stuff so here's how this is
gonna work the teams are Sal and Faust
and Jolie and Rob so I'm sorry swim
teams so here's what we're gonna do okay
red dice will be a Robins and Joel
question blue dice will be a Sal and
Faust question okay it's an easy thing
right we'll go down the same thing
you'll each get your questions
if you then have what what time there
should be give to come up with an answer
so that we're not like sitting for 10
minutes what's the Jeopardy rule yeah 30
seconds okay
since I'm the one hosting the stream you
guys should all like have separate tasks
going so you can discuss things okay so
we're gonna 30 seconds that's be the
rules okay so I'm gonna get the counter
going here all right and we're gonna do
this for the rest of the podcast and
we're gonna see who is more
knowledgeable about marbles for the
regular it's not put them caviar is out
there joel has an extreme advantage
because he has literally a guy that went
by the name Marvel explained like what's
I have a plus I have a series of videos
titled the like the timeline of the more
you guys want to have the three of you
against Rob you know if it's a massacre
we'll just do a final round like a Joel
alright guys first what Reds over there
alright so Rob it's Rob and Joel you've
got an Iron Man question Sal and foul
Scott iron I got our villains okay so
I'll give solemn vows to avenge but
because Faust doesn't know a lot about
cinematic event a universe they'll get
their question first giving them 10 more
seconds on top of okay sounds good yes
yeah
alright so get a stopwatch okay here we
go well a monster that a meal bronc
blonde sky turns into the abomination
final answer that was your thirty
Seconds to roll with and then well
actually will do with like one than the
other that makes more sense
we lose if we don't get the question
right does the question go to the team
yes can we openly discuss I'll ask the
question the other team gets 30 seconds
to decide what the answer is if they
don't get it it goes the other team and
we'll go and then if it doesn't go their
chat can try and get it ok cool and
we'll see what's the win at the end I
don't have a piece of paper to write
this down so Joel yeah let the chat keep
the score because I get so fronts Allen
Foust you've got yes ok should I do it
like this oh all right so the Iron Man
question is I'm gonna almost guess the
Alpha how quickly they can answer this
who is Iron Man oh uh yeah I don't know
some guy you know it's the senator from
I am man to man we're good at this game
here we go Rob and Joel you got a
villains question while Faust n Sal got
a Captain America question oh all right
so what Captain America question is who
plays Captain America has to answer best
answer this Faust you have to only 20
seconds left
why do I have to do this vapors man's
question is what villains said it was
banner oh [ __ ] now it's much more
obscure ok so it obviously has to be The
Hulk movie there's only one Hulk movie
that
the Edward Norton one that's considered
in continuity by as far as Trivial
Pursuit that that is now is Thunderbolt
Ross considered a villain cuz that
sounds like something more that's what
Ross would say than the abomination
would I know answer yeah I'm gonna say
Thunderbolt Ross you got it till I turn
the movie oh I'm so excited
Spartacus some of them are really
obscure so whatever strap that was the
second unit director alright so you guys
have Hulk Salim Faust and yellow
Explorer for you guys alright so good
whole question is name the actor who
plays Emil Blonsky fest you know it's
Tim Roth yes he was
coffee shop guy he was also the he was
also the the bellhop in four rooms so
it's due to the Thor question is Hawkeye
first appeared in Thor is played by
actor mr. Joel or even I guess twenty
stark Robin Joel have the Hulk so the
Captain America question is what actor
plays Steve Rogers best friend James
Buchanan Barnes fast if you've got it
I'm glad you guys got this I think it's
Sebastian Stan no wait yes wait all
right so the Hulk question is name the
actor who plays general Ross oh um
William Hurt
is he hurt The Villages William Hurt
yeah right
he's simultaneously tricking people into
believing they're living in like the
15th century while fighting the
Incredible Hulk Salim Faust Hulk for
Joel and Rob let me get a Scarlet Witch
question I'm gonna be on it crazy check
that warp reality the villains question
is the agent Jespers agent Jasper
Sitwell is played by what actor Oh Oh
God
that's rough he's been into so much he's
been in specialist he's been on the TV
shows I could never tell you I - no I
think it's Jasper Sitwell by the way yes
boys I do not know and I will never do
all right there is halal Nando's Oh
Maximiliano horrendous that was okay for
you guys
what is the hulk's of their name who
wrote the screenplay for The Incredible
Hulk
the guy who directed it was also the guy
who did unleash that I really like and
like he has like one good movie in one
bad movie before you get an answer
finally all right Salim Faust that pen
holy cow
are you serious no he looked it up
except a screenwriter do we get a yellow
card now for looking stuff but I'm from
England I'm gonna cheat he's gonna come
over here and colonize all right chat
chat gets that point by default on both
sides the chat it's an automatic two
points
oh god my apparently updating my geforce
experience every day
alright so Chad gets two points so what
is the point total at now chat
alright channel world let's see it
do you guys have a fruit salad Faust
Joel and Ron have villains which is rare
cos Hulk is just one movie freakin movie
what color question is name the actress
who plays dr. Betty Ross live time ding
ding ding ding yay come back I hopefully
really don't seem to which is sad cuz
she could be red she-hulk and how cool
with that big whoever suggested gameshow
music it's now playing prices bright
music in the background so the question
for you guys is villains oh god what is
the name of the alien army that loki
hopes to use to conquer earth is it to
out we've said we said it was the guy
Zach when you asked a screenplay
question you're gonna give us points
Chitauri to me oh it sounds like some
kind of ripoff of Chipotle yeah alright
you both have the Captain America
questions so we're going for a lightning
round I'm going to ask you to whichever
team can answer it first you guys will
get the ante points ready bilko
who plays dr. Abraham Earth's earned
skin in Captain America the First
Avenger
Stanley - no not Stanley Tucci Stanley
Tucci all right now we have a team in
the lead finally all right we've got a
four question for Mouse and Sal Faust
will get bonus points with his hair if
he doesn't own Thor movies are the ones
I've seen the least because I like them
the least not Thor question is named the
acclaimed Shakespearean actor who
directed Thor's easy and it's bran oh
right
I know bonus points though because our
Thor guy over there didn't do it I keep
reduce pronouncing their names because
you try pronouncing these things off the
cards okay and the whole question for
the two Hulk like figures on our screen
name the actor who plays the pizza
loving lab technician oh wait it's the
original TV show Hulk it's um no no he
was the security guy at the door he
wasn't the technician was the original
to you oh well but but pizza loving cuz
he brings him pizza to get in doesn't he
it's it's it's got to be Ferrigno
because he brings him the pizza get in
our rig no that's the that's that you're
thinking from the first one and you're
both wrong now and Faust you have a all
right can you repeat the question yes I
can't name the actor who plays the pizza
loving lab technician was there a pizza
loving country in the Incredible Hulk
lab technician
house I mean I've got the entire cast in
front of me the end of this with chat do
you have the answer to who is the actor
who plays the pizza loving a lab
technician a what they have Iron Bowl
Hulk Tony Grendel got it Martin story
right so that's three to the chat so
it's five six and three no no no they
should have six six run no yeah they
have six you have five or what do you
guys I don't know they got a day a
nervous
all right so we'll statics got at six
six three okay Sal and Faust you have
Iron Man Joel and Rob you have Avengers
mmm it actually was Hulk but I'm gonna
rotate it to Avengers cuz one movie but
uh alright so for the Iron Man question
where does Tony not want to see the
photo he takes with the soldier posted
Facebook MySpace
Friendster or occupied it's my space
David also Jim Cramer's Mad Money that
shows up in those movies they're the
ones who jump off a rooftop aiming for
the bushes bushes
what does Loki say you're right before
he uses his spear to control Hawkeye's
mind that is that's specific that's
specific in particular I've seen that
movie so what does he say we're gonna do
this again oh my god
dude I swear to God rake if you not stop
you know what let's redo it it's your
fear it's Drake interpreter all right
you guys times up what you got anything
for me oh I'm controlling your mind oh
great man you're killing me I'm
controlling your mind son is not the
answer
all right South and Foust do you have
the answer okay this is what is Loki say
to Hawkeye right before I before he
takes over his mind well I asked for 20
more seconds because Drake was messing
me up I'll pull up my DVD yeah chats
already got it so don't you really yeah
let me make us look bad at our jobs yeah
I do not remember that's a tough one
cuz I know what he says to Iron Man
which is amazing but it's not I don't
remember that is a specific pole that's
alright alright give it to the Chad Chad
said it you have heart you missed some
member that I knew it was some kind of
like dry pun like that I knew it was
something man when I was confusing it
with the Iron Man one for later but no
he says it to him but not too hot yeah I
know I was thinking cool line that he
says to Iron Man not you have heart
somebody says you my [ __ ] alright next
questions we have a Hulk you know what
not a Hulk we're gonna do a Avengers
question for a salad Faust okay Captain
America question for Joel and Rob we're
done with oh no for ellic we've had a
moratorium on Marvel's very much said no
more Hulk unless he's teaming up yeah
alright so the Avengers question is hold
on our Saturday morning music has now
got to start over again all right so our
Avengers question is when a character is
mind controlled by Loki what color do
their eyes turn silent Fausto
in blue that's it right there
you just you got it cuz the same color
is a crystal yeah alright I would have
said hey oz if you're so amazing at this
say like you see now we're debating
colors cuz I would have said pale cuz
like they get that glazed over on being
the control the card says blue so you're
wrong this is a big one which one of the
following health issues did Steve Rogers
not suffer from before becoming Captain
America asthma I'm not good I can't I
hope that's okay now stop down when I'm
not pronouncing it asthma high blood
pressure to Burke Yolo SACEUR scarlet
fever which one did not suffer from
before becoming Captain America scarlet
fever
wrong you got it Salgado
I was not quick on the draw on that
because I remember the sheet very very
vividly that was the one here we go next
one we've got a whole question jo-lynn
throb so here's that here's something to
behold from this point on so we got so
many hulks you can take the Hulk or pick
any other category Oh Hulk can be the
wild what do you think man I mean if we
do avenges there's a chance we'll get
age of Ultron which ISIL most measures
it'll be a speed round because they got
Avengers okay let's not do Avengers do
like Iron Man - liar man
alright Iron Man it is at what age did
Tony Stark graduate summa [ __ ] aloud from
MIT
did he graduate in guy knows me [ __ ] loud
fast you got any guesses I I think I
have the answer
but I don't you go cuz it's more likely
to be right on this right I want to say
it was 16 but I don't know wrong well I
want to pick it up yeah I do want to
pick it up actually um if I can I'm
gonna say what was it 13 wrong yeah
another I haven't even seen it in chat
yet it's I think it's 15 wrong 14 year
old is it an age between 1 and 20 yes
but then they go right ok met point
they're all saying 14 that is not all
our home
it's a we've gone into speed around
whoever we can get it first 18 years old
wrong 5 6 7 8 9 same long 17 Rob tick
Wow awesome what was a Vin Diesel say
doesn't matter if you win by an inch or
a module and Rob is after Loki steals
the tesseract at what level does Nick be
reclassified the threat 1 5 7 or 10 what
do you think Joel I want to say 5 I was
gonna say what level 7 is the thing from
the show it's like you just did chained
level 7 and I feel like I should
remember it's like well obviously it
would be the biggest one but I'm hate
myself because I can't remember uh
alright Chad and Joel and Robb get the
point so go ahead throw it on your honor
with you guys to chat oh do you think
edit I was like apparently they saying
they did so they can have the point
which were Joe and Robb I mean what does
the card say did we get away yeah what
does the card say I don't know what was
your answer for this we didn't we didn't
make an answer oh girl with like seven
it is correct
see that was a team effort we hope that
was I remember that that's the highest
level
like I have the chat window sitting over
here and you've got Ironman again Joel
and Rob you have villains but I will
give you the option to pick it up a
category okay I like villains all right
so for the Ironman question was does us
what are yeah that's you guys
what are Tony Stark's parents names
what are Tony Stark's parents names by
this point you should know his dad's
like five other movies yeah
I'm slipping my mind right now I can't
remember his dad's name actually yeah I
don't know you don't know
no all right Joel and Rob Howard and
Reese work there yes
all right the villains question for Joel
and Rob is in which of the following
films is shield director Nick Fury seen
reporting to a secret shadow council
Thor the Avengers Captain America the
Winter Soldier or Iron Man - this one's
pretty obvious the Avengers I don't
worth to the Avengers it's that one okay
I thought it was the Avengers it's
adventures the shadow council with
powers Boothe is it The Avengers because
they misprinted the card it's got all of
the answers on the back they're like oh
the world council like we're doing that
really being around for so long you're
involved hmm all right question is and
in the first war with the frost giants
which one of his eyes - did Oh Dan lose
left our nest
raah is it left it is it was wrong Rob
your team loses hey hey south side left
-
which it around okay okay
so fast got one answer correct was so it
was a we're going double speed all four
questions okay why not
which one of the following is another
name for Asgard Oh God
Vanna hem heaven realm eternal or hell
realm eternal yeah I was gonna say realm
eternal Rob got it nice all those other
places are places but they do call it
alright moving thousand Sally you've got
a cult question giving you the wild card
well Bob and Joel have also got a halt
question the wild card I think we've
gotten all the easy ones off hog it's a
to be lab text okay so salad vows what
would you like to take your question
from yes what do you want what do you
think rocks included the one he destroys
how many punching bags does Captain
America have at the gym these are for
wrong Joel and uh Rob want to pick that
one up I was gonna say for action oh
there's there's a one you knocks there's
a one he breaks there's the one he picks
up puts on his shoulder and then there's
the one he has in his hand which is
three and then maybe they are they kind
of the ones against the walls I think
there's like maybe two or three more I
must be okay I'm gonna go with six wrong
shat really don't see it in the chat
that's a rough numbers question man
maybe like seven number seven is the
right answer
oh really is that I don't have the
punching bag attention all right so Rob
and sell Rob Robin Joel what category
would you like your question from
you think what haven't we seen a lot of
yet we haven't seen his room then I just
category but her adventures okay okay I
guess let's do Avengers then I that's
the same question ready did it yeah oh
crap uh uh we haven't even been which
yes because in America okay
during training when faced with a live
grenade what does Steve Rogers do
Dorset's kicks it dives on it or runs
from it
that dives on it like a hero alright
that's another point for you guys like a
big hero man he did dodge and duck
alright to the challenging questions you
mean those ones weren't challenging
solid fast and villains on robben Joel
let's do it
the avengers question is name the actor
who plays hawk wait what we already did
that the actress who plays hawkeye his
wife which villain is once referred to
as howard stark's long life a lifelong
friend and Ally Obadiah Stane yeah hey
the Iron Monger
you're right okay you both get I just
love how it was like everybody had
obscure villain see ya all right we've
got a cap question for Joe for salad
Faust in a ironmen question for Joel and
Rob the cap question is who is the head
of Hydra hitler's research division who
is the head of you know that's funny
because shield has actually started
retconning a bunch of that stuff right
mm-hm
that is incorrect of the Hydra division
yeah of Hitler yeah this research
division was not the Red Skull it's
always huh I mean is this human name
oh yeah you should probably all knew who
it was I was going off on what the cards
said my answered the other one in the
opposite direction if I had said Iron
Monger aka Obadiah Stane instead of the
other way around what I yeah well in any
case
Joel Wright where is Tony Stark's
Oceanwide mansion located Malibu I'm
saying what is the address I say you
should give us now that point for a red
skull wait now we're given something
funnier though by the way I don't like
you so alright now we are coming to the
end of our show guys so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go through five
lightning rounds by live lightning
rounds okay
my my a lot of lightning why not there's
a lot of for you know why not alright
we're gonna first see how fast what do
you guys answers an Avengers question
named the actor who plays vision
south all right we're gonna go what said
no look at look at sounds like [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna go with another Avengers
question honey I got one right name the
only Avenger that can calm the Hulk blah
that's it that's the Joel that's a job
good job Joel Joel with the quickness oh
here we go alright alright this to be a
good one see you guess this one in a
hurry Captain America a sign from the
Super Soldier Serum itself
what other component is needed to
stimulate growth by the way electricity
arteries yep raw Gotti's alright here we
go again here we go again
I'm looking for a tricky one on this
list here do don't do that oh here we go
yeah thora question
and fast we'll get ten seconds before
you guys to answer this one another no
don't get even more embarrassing no I
don't where's actually my favorite phase
one if you can believe it I actually
really like that one after arguing with
his father what oversized piece of
furniture does Thor flip over in a fit
of rage it can I just go oh go go I
don't want to see the table I'll give it
to you both double K oh I knew it but
they knows like no copy a table all
right all right hey what's the score
Chad I'm curious world can you chat can
you rig it so Sal and I are winning feel
sorry what do we win besides bragging
rights you bragging rights that's
basically it was the chat because this
is the last question is it gonna be a
good one 14 18 and 6 6 nice so is the 18
of Joel and Rob No all right here we go
this isn't gonna matter but let's see
who can get this final one you know what
whoever gets this one gets 5 points Oh
making the entire game which two of the
following were not included in Tony
Stark / and Tony Stark's personality
profile volatile self-obsessed selfless
depraved or does not play well with
others
supposin depraved you both got it that's
weird that you both got it so we can't
enter we should give it to Sal because
obviously he compared with me where do
Captain America and Black Widow meet for
the first time
on the Oh got that one again okay okay
we're going with a simple at no wait uh
Obadiah stand compares Tony's you know
your copy of Lord of the Rings gets a
better goatee for Ironman they're gonna
make a movie called the podcast the
story of us all culminates in this
moment okay we need an x-men Trivial
Pursuit because then I will be down on
that like it's gotta be more than just
this I'm gonna buy you will struggle on
an x-men to real receipt I promise you
oh yeah
dominate in pursuit next week or do a
regular podcast if I can't find a copy
that'll be rude I will find a copy we'll
do some x-men trip do this for true
pursuit is fun guys thank you so much
for joining us today we will be bring
you a Jessica Jones spoiler cast either
later this week or in our normal slot
next week if you did enjoy this kind of
game or this can of episode where we do
kind of like games and trivia let us
know we'll do more of them there's
plenty of games out there that we can
drag together to test the knowledge of
your favorite comic book youtubers hmm
and on that note just don't care about
the movies that much movie trivia
pursued wait I've seen all the x-men
movies multiple times they need to be
angry
what kind of black guys wondering where
I got this Trivial Pursuit game it is I
found it at Gamestop today we went to go
jig it just cause they had it sitting in
there in that little like they have oh
nice yeah it was I think it was 15 bucks
total so for those you guys you want to
get it for yourself and according to
this this is volume one while you two is
like phase to pursue to be funny because
we'll see how would you awful I would do
all right on I doubt if they don't know
why obscure DC villain stop is not
sponsoring us if anyone's got any pull
with game stock company you made that
trip absurd game to them its Hasbro guys
make a fine product just product we love
their stuff and their shirts send them
over all right guys on that note we'll
be seeing you well later thank you for
joining us and if you stick around later
tonight I'm about 50/50 on if we'll be
coming back streaming on this channel
yet again zydeco may be bringing you the
Just Cause 3 stream from ela's real
monster gaming channel otherwise we will
see you tomorrow with it if we don't
come back tonight but make sure you
follow this channel if you want to get
up-to-date on that news and follow us
all on Twitter at com
story at sell says what at the DVD
grouch cuz he's got to be weird at
comics explaining in at rhythm beats
2940 what is it it's rhythm beat music
alright if you follow all those you'll
know when anything goes live on this
channel if it's gaming it'll be my stuff
so make sure you follow at comics Torian
thank you guys so happy oh yeah it
follow out the weekly pulled by the way
we're the weekly poll you can follow
that too if you want to yeah da all
right guys thank you so much we'll see
you next time peace